thank you
[Music]
i can hear a little creek over here
there's a lot of cool rock formation
around these creeks and we might be able
to find a good shelter
[Music]
are you coming with me
[Music]
i think this would be an awesome spot
we've got three walls
throw a tarp over the roof man we'd be
good to go except
big rock here and a rock there there's
just nowhere to lay down
[Music]
should we follow this creek all right
let's see what happens
look at this nathan
yeah let's keep going and see if we find
the bottom of the canyon
look over here
that's cool should we go see if we can
find our way down there
there's like a whole cave behind that
waterfall of ice
that is a big one
how's that one
oh i just stepped in the water right
from there
all the way there the ice is thin and
there's water underneath
this place is cool look at this we're
just
right in the middle of this little
canyon here
oh that's water that ice broke
underneath me
there's like a tree under the ice
look how clear this ice is it's like
crystal
you just see right through it
[Music]
oh
oh you want to come back here watch out
you get wet buddy
yeah look at this oh this is slick
you're on the back side of an ice
waterfall is that cool
see if i can do this without without
biting it
hold on nate don't slip
all right nathan i think this looks like
an awesome spot
oh let's find some dead trees
[Applause]
um
i think that's fine nate i don't think
we need to worry about icicles falling
on us anymore
for me
see if you can karate chop
yeah karate dab yeah
slide down
i'm always super paranoid that i'm going
to run out of firewood in the middle of
the night and so i always end up
gathering way more than i need
but i think i've got a good pile for
right now i we need to get the shelter
up
i'm going to build the shelter out of a
12 foot by 12 foot tarp and a couple of
these poles i think it's going to be one
of the best ones
i've ever made
oh my therm-a-rest mattress just split
these things are
ultra light ultra compact but they're
very fragile
this is my winter whale titanium
backpacking stove
it's a wood stove only weighs a few
pounds this thing is so light
and it's really easy to put together
that little roll of titanium right there
turns into a seven foot stove pipe
the stove pipe will melt the tarp if it
touches it
so i've got to use these fork sticks to
keep the tarp
away from the stove pipe
uh
do you want spaghetti or cup of noodle
all right cup of little it is
now you can boil water by putting a
kettle on top of the stove but it's not
particularly fast
and nathan's really hungry so i busted
out my little backup
butane stove which i always carry with
me and this thing will boil water
pretty quick
all right nathan are ramen noodles your
favorite camping food
oh some warm food feels good
i found if you take a little bit of the
frozen wood and put it above the stove
it heats it up it dries it out so that
when you're ready to soak the fire
it burns really well of course one
downside of drying your wood on top of
the stove
is it can catch on fire so let's uh
let's pull that off
that one's dry about half the time i do
these videos i don't have cell service
so i use my garmin inreach mini to
communicate with my wife
through text messages this thing allows
me to send and receive text message
messages through the iridium satellite
network and that works anywhere on the
globe
and it also allows my wife to track her
locations
uh in case something happens and i can
send an sos with this little emergency
button over here on the right
and i can use it like a gps device so
i'm just gonna send a message to becca
let her know we're safe and sound and
warm
i'll get your camp booties on
there's been a big pain in my butt and i
roll back my mouth and there's a little
stuff here
got you
tiny little bump let's get it done
i've only got one pack of hot chocolate
left
well we're getting ready to go to bed
and i have learned my lesson from
previous winter camping trips i brought
a wide
neck bottle yeah we're not getting out
of our bag tonight
good night buddy
there's a lot of salt and ramen broth
you know how cold it's got to get to
freeze that solid
jeez i thought water bottle
well here on the outdoor boys channel we
post new videos every saturday morning
and it's seven a.m on a saturday morning
so i've got to walk out of this canyon
to get enough cell service to be able to
post my video
there we go there's your new video oh
i'm gonna go back by that fire it's cold
out here
my hands are frozen
oh it was cold last night my bag was
barely keeping it together
hey nathan were you warm yeah
nathan's bag is so much better than mine
i gotta get one of those
yeah nathan's got the feather friends
plover it's a negative 25 bag
it is so sweet and the best part is
feathered friends will customize the
length for you and so i had them shorten
it so it's a
perfect nathan sized bag
you ready for some oatmeal bud
as much as i hate to say it i think i
need to get dressed and get
up and doing stuff it is
cold
there's a lot of these really cool rock
formations to explore around here and as
soon as we get done breaking camp
i want to go hike to a frozen waterfall
and i think we might be able to find a
cave as well so
that's gonna be kind of cool but first i
need to get cleaned up in case you're
wondering how i secured the tarp to this
rock face
i just had these little wooden wedges
that i jammed into the cracks right
there
and over on this side i tied it off to
an icicle now we're going to get our
tarp
off without letting it touch the stove
and get melted like i did last time
[Music]
wow
[Music]
well this has been one of the coolest
places i've ever camped
but i think it's time to go explore some
more stuff
you want to go hike and see a cave in
waterfall yeah all right let's drop our
packs here so we don't have to carry
them up we'll come back for them okay
we'll just stash them behind the tree
over here
i think we might be close well look at
that
like cave full of icicles
oh look at this this is cool
oh well careful don't fall down here bud
careful don't slip down there whoa look
at that that's cool
wait for me we go together hold on look
at this
there's a big creek down there
there was a small cave at the bottom of
that ravine
but it looked like it had three feet of
water in the bottom i thought maybe the
water would be frozen this time of year
we could get in it
but i would hate to fall down that thing
and be stuck in that water
yeah it's so pretty in the wintertime oh
look at this tree
it's cracked right down there and you
can hear it
yeah hear that wind's about to knock
that tree over
you okay
oh trail's getting a bit faint
oh this is pretty awesome nate you glad
we came here well there's supposed to be
a big waterfall around here too
but i'm not sure if we can find it daddy
are you crazy man you're taking your
coat off
that boy's crazy there we go right where
we left it
i'm so glad you came with me on this
camp out nathan yeah did you have fun
yeah well listen guys if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
hiking and camping videos
i'll put a link in the description to
our hiking and camping
video playlist and if you guys want to
see more videos like this don't forget
to click subscribe we put out new videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys if you like this video
don't forget to check out the outdoor
boys youtube channel where we have
hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
let's do this